[Música]
los días la verdad es que es increíble
nunca me había pasado que a una
neurobióloga verdad joven revolucionaria
me vio encantada de esto de lo que voy a
hablar yo es de la revolución del
conocimiento y fijaos empezaré un poco
como tomás molina
esta máquina de escribir es la que yo
utilicé para escribir lo que en aquel
momento se llamaba la tesina de grado
que ahora sería como la tesis de máster
estaba bien no estaba mal me habían
prestado una olivetti y solo tenía un
problema ahí veis a nuestra secretaria y
abajo en la derecha que cada vez que te
equivocabas y en una letra no pasaba
nada le ponía letras set y picaba encima
pero si te equivocabas una página en una
frase tenías que repetir todo el
capítulo otra vez
la verdad es que eran hablando de hace
36 años así como si todavía mayor que
tomás pues cuando yo empecé la facultad
pues se acaba de empezar tomar el poder
margaret thatcher acaban de estrenar
apocalypse now y el súper novedosa y
tecnológico era el walkman por cien
podías ir por la calle escuchando música
es que era una pasada y no
compartiéndola con los demás como con la
radio no ya que la verdad es que era una
época pues muy muy diferente hacíamos
cosas como que memorizábamos los números
de teléfono chicos impresionante los
memorizamos y si no los buscábamos en la
guía telefónica
si necesitábamos información no íbamos a
internet íbamos a una biblioteca
todavía tengo todos los tomos de la
enciclopedia britannica en mi casa que
ahora mis hijos los usan para subir la
pantalla del ordenador
fijaos no había teléfonos ahora los
teléfonos son ordenadores tienen cámara
de fotos tienen puedes navegar por
internet y de todo no dentro de poco
adam un city printing nos mostrará las
cosas en realidad virtual cuando yo era
joven
llamábamos desde las cabinas de teléfono
entonces cuando te vas de viaje pues
hasta que no encontrabas una cabina de
teléfonos no llamabas a casa para decir
hay que llegar viene
bueno como veis se dan tiempos un
poquito diferentes cuando yo hacía mi
tesina de grado este chico mark
zuckerberg era un crío pero fijaos lo
que pasó desde que empezó con facebook
hasta ahora el número de gente que
utiliza facebook se ha
multiplicado por muchos cientos
también es verdad que las cosas han
cambiado en otros términos en cómo nos
relacionamos yo sí quería saber lo que
decía mi presidente del gobierno tenía
que comprarme el periódico ahora lo lees
en twitter
no
y qué más hay pues hemos cambiado todo
hemos cambiado la manera de
relacionarnos aquí os pongo parte de las
miles de cosas pero yo que sé aquí
tenemos a nuestro amigo ibai en tweets
que me encanta por cierto tenemos que el
5 por ciento de los americanos declaran
que han conocido a su pareja por una de
estas citas a ciegas de las citas de mit
y tal y podemos hacer estas cosas que
ahora se han puesto muy de moda después
de la pandemia no hemos recuperado el
chat roulette a ver con quién me toca
hablar o el hombre girl e ibi pagamos en
bitcoins que por cierto es de las
mejores inversiones que puedes hacer que
lo sepáis los que todavía no tengáis
bitcoins que ahora os podéis comprar
como un céntimo de bitcoin o una cosa
así
fijaos de todas formas el año pasado la
pandemia es la que de verdad ha hecho
que la tecnología cambie nuestras vidas
el año pasado nos unificamos
y las frases más escuchadas han sido
está moldeado
a quien no le ha pasado es un clásico de
zoom o puedes ver mi pantalla podéis ver
mi pantalla
bueno en todos esos cambios en realidad
ya estaban pasando los peces que han
permeado a toda la sociedad rural y ya
estábamos ahí ya estábamos en lo que se
llama la cuarta revolución en la que
todo está cambiando y a veces está
cambiando con un poco de reticencia por
parte de la ciudadanía ay dios mío la
robotización como me va a influir y sin
embargo durante la pandemia
teníamos robots que hacían que los
sanitarios no tuvieran que ser en
contacto directo con los pacientes por
ejemplo tenemos el internet de las cosas
nosotros estamos haciendo proyectos de
investigación en los que hacemos un
seguimiento longitudinal de nuestros
pacientes teniendo conectada la
información de los fitbit para ver qué
ejercicio hacen del gps para ver dónde
están dónde van etc
que os voy a decir del big data es que
antes hacer lo que se llama un
experimento de cómicas que significa
hacer un catálogo de todas tus proteínas
o de todos tus rda mensajeros o de todos
tus genes es una cosa como súper
especial y súper extraña y estoy
hablando de no hace tanto de hace 10
años
vale en este momento las o mi caso lo
que hacemos sistemáticamente antes
estaba escuchando en la presentación de
uno de mis estudiantes que contaba un
single nuclea y a grace sec que es otro
que suena así pues en realidad
simplemente el catálogo de genes que
expresa cada célula
y que os voy a decir de la inteligencia
artificial en este momento la utilizamos
para un montón de cosas ya lo sabéis en
ciencia también
fijaos nos queda mucho por ver nos queda
mucho por venir y el futuro está ahí
está nada a un paso y vamos a empezar a
hablar de noia dejen 5g vamos a empezar
a hablar ya que estás hablando de de 6 g
se está hablando de internet en 3.0 se
está hablando de los metaversos hace
poco en for night un rapero hizo un
concierto en metaverso y la gente volaba
por la playa y cosas de estas
bueno todas las revoluciones
quizás de todas esas la que más
interesantes es la convergencia entre
todas las tecnologías digitales físicas
con la biología porque eso está llamado
a cambiar el mundo y ya lo está
cambiando ya tenemos quirófanos para
hacer operaciones desde otro país desde
otra ciudad
quirófanos en los que podemos hacer
operaciones tele asistidas con 5g en
barcelona se ha hecho se hizo en 2019
pues la primera con este súper quirófano
que se llama óptimo que permite pues que
personas desde un experto desde otro
país pues pueda dirigir una operación
aquí en barcelona
no sólo eso la revolución de las cómicas
que hablábamos antes y de la
telemedicina la telemedicina en este
momento es está creciendo un 53 por
ciento más rápido que cualquier otro
tipo de cuidados sanitarios
estamos hablando de la revolución de la
genómica personalizada ahora ya hay
servicios directos al consumidor de
secuenciación genómica y te pueden
mandar tu secuencia al móvil y la puedes
porque un compartir por facebook si
quieres no se van a enterar de nada de
nuestros amigos pero bueno pero ahí te
pueden decir te predicen lo que es lo
que el riesgo tienes de tener
determinadas enfermedades y todas esas
tecnologías nos están ayudando a que
podamos tener cada vez más información
cada vez más big data identificar lo que
llamamos biomarcadores es decir qué
moléculas en mi sangre predicen que voy
a tener un riesgo de padecer una
determinada enfermedad porque así yo me
puedo adelantar y puedo hacer no
medicina que trate si no medicina que
prevenga que impida que yo me ponga
enfermo vale
antes hablábamos de los oráculos
genómicos seguro que todos habéis visto
gattaca que por cierto son las siglas de
los nucleótidos no sé si lo sabíais pero
ahora hablamos de edición genética quien
no hable oído hablar del cris percas el
famoso crease percas son unas tijeras
genéticas basadas en un sistema de
defensa de las bacterias y esas tijeras
genéticas que nos van a permitir no sólo
curar enfermedades sino también hacer
neuro mejora y hacer mejora sanitaria
para mí la más importante como
neurocientífica es la neuro evolución
que es la neuro revolución dejamos este
señor es donde antiago ramón y cajal yo
empecé a hacer neurociencia porque
admiraba y una persona con unos medios
tan exiguos con ese microscopio de la
señorita pepis que veis ahí fuera capaz
de extraer ley y reglas que todavía
perduran que todavía están ahí que han
cambiado la neurociencia
pero ahora estamos yendo más allá la
neuro revolución supone que amplificamos
nuestras capacidades humanas a través de
las máquinas aquí veis pues como con la
mente podemos mover un brazo robótico o
podemos tener unas gafas de realidad
aumentada que aumenten la información
que me llega o podemos hacer sustitución
sensorial las personas que no pueden ver
pueden ver a través de sistemas como
estos nosotros en el laboratorio usamos
cosas como esta trazamos neuronas en
realidad virtual en las que tú te metes
dentro del cerebro ves las neuronas a tu
alrededor y las re sigues
o por ejemplo estamos utilizando los
interfaces cerebro-ordenador para ayudar
a personas con discapacidad o
tetrapléjicas que no pueden andar no se
puede mover no pueden hablar a
comunicarse mediante una pantalla de
ordenador nosotros hemos hecho ese
estudio con marc guardia este chico que
veis aquí que fue nuestro voluntario
cero
y este chico aquí no lo veis muy bien
pero si me dicen las pantallitas veis
que con su mente está moviendo un cubo
en una pantalla de ordenador
fijaos en este momento se utilizan esos
elementos pues por ejemplo para ver si
los alumnos están atentos en clase o no
es una imagen de japón o para mover pues
drones o coches no hace tanto a los
jugadores del barça se les ofreció la
posibilidad de hacer una carrera de
coches con estos sistemas cerebrales no
lo hicieron muy bien por cierto o te
puedes mover en uno de esos metaversos
en 3d en realidad virtual mediante la
actividad mental o puedes utilizarlo
para la neurorrehabilitación fijaos para
más allá todavía los implantes los
famosos implantes que de hecho nosotros
ya utilizamos a la derecha veis del
paciente una vez activado el implante y
se corrige en este caso su enfermedad de
parkinson sus síntomas no el temblor la
espasticidad pero en este momento ya no
sabéis a lo más que ya está diciéndonos
que más de cien mil personas ya llevan
implantes y cada vez eso vaya más es
decir estamos de alguna manera
propiciando esa simbiosis hombre-máquina
pero dejadme que haga una reflexión este
es mi padre mi padre neurocirujano aquí
está con su polígrafo en el primer
brainlab que hubo en eeuu que él estuvo
formo parte de ello y él empezó una vez
un discurso diciendo voy a hablarles de
una historia triste una historia
decepcionante es la historia de los
avances el decía en medicina
fijaos esta generación de hungry
jiangmen lo que criticaba era que detrás
de toda esa
aluvión tecnológico tiene que haber un
debate bioético tenemos que pensar a
dónde nos lleva
tenemos que pensar cómo nos lleva
y todos sabemos yo he puesto el título
de la peli está el bueno el feo y el
malo que la tecnología al final es
expresión de la voluntad humana y claro
que la podemos utilizar pues en
rehabilitación o para cosas buenas pero
ya dar para está utilizando estas
tecnologías estás neuro tecnologías en
entornos militares eso está ahí ya está
ahí
entonces yo siempre digo que la especie
humana es una es una especie que tiene
los genes de lo mejor y de lo peor somos
capaces de crear las sociedades
complejas tenemos un potencial de
pensamiento de creación brutal
pero también ninguna otra especie tiene
tanta capacidad o la misma capacidad de
mentir robar engañar o destruir
entonces dejadme que haga un pequeño
pensamiento en ese sentido la pandemia
nos ha dejado un toque de atención
nos ha recordado que nuestros mayores
tienen derecho a la vida digna no está
recordado que hay mucha gente que va a
sufrir también otra pandemia la pandemia
de la pobreza nos ha recordado algo que
tomás también ha dicho el cambio
climático entonces no nos podemos quedar
quietos nos podemos quedar parados
entonces yo lo que digo yo lo que os
propongo a todos vosotros que sois el
futuro
os propongo una revolución humana os
propongo que retomemos todas nuestras
capacidades todo eso que nos hace
humanos
y lo pongamos en marcha
iban a venir otras pandemias lo hemos
dicho la pandemia de la desigualdad de
la pobreza estamos fomentando que haya
muchas personas que se vayan a quedar
atrás y eso no puede ser porque al final
los que hacemos el mundo somos todos no
sólo unos pocos privilegiados
las otras pandemias también son nuestros
propios estereotipos nosotros ponemos
etiquetas a todo el mundo estos son down
estos son enferma de wilson estos son
o parálisis cerebral y no son gente y
ahí tenéis gente que son músicos ella es
una ingeniera informática
matemáticos o artistas
entonces la quinta revolución para mí la
quinta revolución no tiene que dejar de
lado la tecnología al revés la tiene que
abrazar
prueba tiene que abrazar de otra forma y
lo primero es que no tenemos que luchar
contra nuestros estereotipos a mí
siempre me dicen estás luchando contra
el autismo no hay que luchar contra la
ignorancia
hay que luchar contra la falta de
conocimiento martin luther king dijo que
nada en el mundo es más peligroso que la
ignorancia sincera y la estupidez
concienzuda
conocimiento no desinformación mirar
tres segundos a una página web no te da
conocimiento hay que pensar sobre ello
porque eso sí que te va a dar
conocimiento eso sí que te va a hacer
libre eso sí que te va a dar capacidad
crítica
eso es conocimiento
y luego la revolución de los diferentes
tenemos que empezar a valorar a todo el
mundo a todo el mundo eso qué quiere
decir que nos estamos perdiendo un
montón de talento por el camino
daniel tammet este chico es autista pero
es escritor tiene una capacidad
matemática impresionante
stephen wilson llama a la cámara humana
de una escena un segundo y es capaz de
reproducir la
exactamente como ves
o estos dibujos estos dibujos son de
nuria nuria type asperger y le cuesta
mucho las relaciones sociales y entre
trabajar en una empresa que se llama la
casa de carlota de un amigo mío y en la
casa de carlota le dieron una cajita de
esas de tampones de letras de tampones y
ella hizo esto
qué retrato más bonito quién es hijo es
mi abuela
y esto que pone recordarte dice es que
he hecho su cara con un poema que se
llama recordarte y ella es capaz de leer
aquí
en la forma correcta ese poema están
todas las letras de todas las palabras
de ese poema
o en este dibujo vio una bailarina y
reprodujo todos los movimientos como si
fuera una cámara de estas que sobreponen
las imágenes
y si tú haces el análisis por ordenador
es exacto
cómo es posible qué sucede en esos
cerebros y cómo es posible que perdamos
la posibilidad de entenderlo y de
utilizarlo
la revolución que tiene que ser esa
quinta revolución tiene que ser una
revolución abierta ya estamos en ciencia
abierta ya estamos compartiendo no puede
ser que las nuevas tecnologías sólo sean
para unos pocos las nuevas tecnologías
el nuevo conocimiento todo tiene que ser
para todos
para todos tenemos que dejar atrás de
una vez este modelo en el que se
favorece solamente unos pocos
y yo os digo la ciencia el conocimiento
no depende de los científicos depende de
todos vosotros
el general conocimiento no es algo que
hagamos los científicos es algo que
hacéis vosotros
vosotros
la ciencia os necesita pero también
vosotros necesitáis a la ciencia
entonces qué revolución propongo y
espero que todos seáis unos
revolucionarios
propongo una revolución en la que
empecemos a valorar de nuevo el caudal
de pensar conjuntamente no en equipo
todo el equipo ya está pasado pensar
conjuntamente en los problemas que
seamos capaces de desarrollar nuestra
conciencia ecológica hasta el final que
tengamos tecnología para todos que
tengamos esas comunidades virtuales de
aprendizaje que nos ayudan a conectar de
otra manera y que finalmente seamos
capaces de establecer un cambio de
paradigma una regeneración de este
sistema que ya está obsoleto está
obsoleto